pour en parler nous sommes sont delek
depuis leicester avec alister jones
professeur associé de politique à
l'université de montfort de leicester
c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir
alister jones perd 6 d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france comment peut-on
analyser cette proposition de boris
johnson
je pense que paris jackson essaye
d'avancer très prudemment entre la
proposition où l'offre du droit aux
citoyens en conquête qui ont le droit
depuis 1999 82 1997 venir vivre au
réunissant trop contrarier le
gouvernement chinois
le problème c'est la façon dont le
gouvernement chinois réagi cela va bien
au delà de l'accord est terminée lorsque
comme hong kong a été rétrocédée à
l'époque on pensait que ce serait un
état de système on pensait qu'on aurait
une certaine souplesse et pourrait se
tord gouverner dans une certaine mesure
cette loi de sécurité nationale a adopté
à beijing montrent que la chine rôle des
muscles et essaye de saper le système
mis en place tout jusqu'à en 2047 au
moins par le royaume y chante on peut
dire que la chine en frein l'accord
décidées lors de la rétrocession de hong
kong donc si on vous écoute bien c'est
une sorte de lutte de pouvoir qui se
joue là de lutte d'influencé en quelque
sorte oui
du point de vue de positionner sonne et
il ya beaucoup d'autres problèmes en
cours il ya le pré xiti mialot
coronavirus et voilà quelque chose qui
ces joutes encore on pourrait penser
qu'il
ceux là dessus parce que les deux autres
problèmes se développent très mal il y
aura sans doute pas d'accord pour le
prêt dit et la situation avec le
commandât virus est désastreuse au
royaume uni mais avec hong kong il peut
dire regardez je suis un dirigeant à
l'échelle mondiale et j'agis en tant que
dirigeant britannique tient il s'agit de
renforcer ou de rappeler le statut
britannique dans le monde selon bret
johnson alors vous l'avez dit
effectivement on rappelle évidemment
hong kong ancienne colonie d rétrocédée
à la chine en 1997 la chine elle parle
d'esprit colonies là de la part du
royaume uni n'y at-il pas effectivement
une forme d'ingérence dans cette
proposition de boris johnson
le problème c'est que l'accord conclu en
1997 a commencé bien plus tôt
les britanniques et les chinois sont
tombés d'accord sur la façon de
gouverner en compte le royaume uni n'est
souhaitée a permis qu'il n'y aurait pas
d' indépendance complète pour satisfaire
le gouvernement chinois mais en
contrepartie hong kong a beaucoup
d'autonomie et le rôle du royaume uni
c'est de s'assurer que cette autonomie
reste tiers des citoyens hong kong et
des passeports britanniques d'outre-mer
où sont éligibles pour ce passeport ils
peuvent se rendre au royaume uni et
travailler jusqu'à simon 6 mois et cela
pourrait être étendue jusqu'à 12 mois
donc il ya effectivement une relation
étroite entre on compte que le royaume
uni en tant qu'ancienne puissance
coloniale et on pourrait dire que
l'effectif en une obligation de venir
défendre le peuple
hong kong est et c'est ce que boris
johnson semble penser alors dans le même
temps brestois me semble un petit peu
aussi le grand défenseur du break citant
pas nécessairement donc envers en faveur
de l'ouverture
quel intérêt à ce premier ministre
britannique aujourd'hui à tende la main
un pays encore plus lointain même si
vous venez très bien de l'expliquer il
ya des
historique très étroit je voulais que
cela concerne les passeports les
personnes qui ont ce passeport
britannique d'outre-mer peuvent se
rendre au royaume uni il y en a environ
350 milles mais il y en a il pourrait y
avoir au total 3 millions qui peuvent
venir se rendent à travailler au
royaume-uni donc boris johnson essayent
de protéger des personnes qui a possède
le passeport de son pays
sur ce point de vue le britannique la
chine enfreint va à l'encontre de la
corse si cette loi de sécurité nationale
est imposé à hong kong alors cela irait
à l'encontre des droits des citoyens à
hong kong et pour une boris johnson
il s'agit de protéger presse que des
ressortissants britanniques des
personnes qui ont un passeport
britannique
comment cette proposition et elle a
accueilli outre-manche par la population
en majorité on n'en parle pas beaucoup
cela fait quelques gros titres mais il y
à d'autres préoccupations le coronavirus
est bien plus important le président
aussi pour beaucoup de personnes
cela dit concernant la possibilité
d'accueillir trois millions de personnes
au royaume-uni certaines personnes se
demandent si comme on essaye de fermer
les frontières avec le brésil
cela ne représenterait pas le risque
d'avoir un afflux de migrants qui
attendra qu'ils obtiendraient la la
citoyenneté pourrait travailler sur le
marché britannique
donc certaines personnes se demandent
quel est le plan au long terme
et certaines personnes ne considère que
le gouvernement lui même ne sait pas ce
que ce qu'est son plein au long terme
merci à lyster jones professeur associé
de politique à l'université de montfort
de leicester d'avoir été avec nous pour
vu de l'extérieur ce soir